they run cover for these people so the
average person who doesn't have all data
analyze politics
and think things through the average
person is just flipping television
flipping on television flipping the
channels and they stop on certain things
and they go oh my God Republicans must
be horrible and Democrats must be so
nice because that's the way everything's
framed here is noted racist Sunny Hosten
on The View
and I think it takes real courage to
show that you've been knocked down I
think it takes real bravery to allow
people to see your weakness right and we
know that better men's cognitive
abilities have not been compromised it's
about expression right that has been
compromised at Aphasia exactly and you
know this is a smart guy
okay so first off how do we know that
his cognitive abilities have not been
compromised I know they keep saying it
right and doctors who have not uh
examined him say it to the New York
Times and she says it there but how do
we know now again I have total sympathy
with him as a stroke victim and anyone
that is dealing with any cognitive stuff
and having trouble speaking or any of
the things so I am not making a joke
about that at all I'm showing you the
way they run cover imagine if Ted Cruz
suddenly was having trouble speaking
imagine if Rand Paul was slurring his
words and really confused and seemingly
didn't know where he is they would be
going off on it they would be absolutely
going off and and not only they'd be
going off on it and making fun of them
they'd also be saying and you see it
proves that they're that their
constituents are morons and racists and
everything else because no matter
whether the guy can speak or not they're
still going to support them so
everything they do is a lie everything
they do is Ohio thank you